[Music]
one boom welcome to simulation I'm your
host Don sake on now we're sitting down
with Audrey Watson what's up Alan how's
it going is your hosting boom I love it
Ron mentioned the handshake earlier it's
like poof since like really attract
attention to yeah the power the power of
life powder of life force have you done
this yet you put your hand up
go the yes and then it go it like this
yes and then put it together and then
you just look at each other nice there
you go
[Laughter]
instead just a moment of connection just
like this that's so powerful are you
gonna do the thumb hug them hug schedule
like that the thumb hug yeah yeah that's
that that's happening so a little bit of
human connection a little bit of peace
you know that's what we always like to
bring to everybody while we're doing the
show we like to bring you some
interdisciplinary knowledge which we
have today we're talking about Andres
company
Lagaan blue gondola gondola we had to
call it like ental ligand all British
people like to call it ligand all ligand
oh we're legato llegando yeah for
British people they're ligands Americans
call them Loggins Loggins unless they
had British professors and although I
expect you to go lion though I'm gonna
I'm gonna ask for pronunciation like
five times this show that's good yeah
lion though mental like Kendall like
Angela like like handle so like in
though five years now in the making
that's a good time to get amount of time
yeah I realize that it's been seven
years since kind of the moment where
this whole thing started and okay so
yeah we'll get through a journey what
we're talking about gene therapy we're
talking about personalized medicine
we're gonna talk about we're gonna get
into depth and all of that so let's yeah
let's do a little bit about the journey
so you said seven years ago was your
like moment of that you want to get
involved in this
yeah I'm up up to that point where were
you born this born in SoCal and half
Russian my mom's side of the family is
all Russian so grew up speaking Russian
to my mom you up dad's an American it
wasn't I'm Coco vice versa there yeah
and anyhow I was in Boston for like six
years from like the ages of 13 to 19 for
some time wanted to go into music school
then and decided I really liked physics
so into IPI for physics for ER and then
I switched to biomedical engineering
started looking at all the different
landscapes of you know what is
biomedical engineering because really
from just you know
I'm gonna spend the next 20 years of my
life sort of perspective I wanted to be
doing something more impactful than just
you know am I gonna build an app for ya
you know food delivery or something left
to say that's not great but you know
like a lot of people are doing that and
we're still gonna die and that's kind of
frustrating so that's where I started
looking at really the field of you know
biology as a medium for engineering
right yeah and that's really what I like
about bioengineering and biomedical yes
a lot of it focused on you know implants
or bioinformatics you know how do we
deal with all the data from genomics or
you know MRI is that sort of thing yes
but what really struck me is that amidst
all of the data that we could possibly
have around any number of things you
know having our genome sequence having
blood tests all the time we were still
really bound by these limitations
physically as biological creatures in
that we can't really do anything about
that information for the most part and
so what struck me also is that we had
all these tools you know RNAi
therapeutics have been going on for
twenty years all sorts of different gene
therapy modalities now we have CRISPR
but it still has the same problems in
that you can have the best tools for
reprogramming a cell but you need to
actually be able to get those so those
tools to the right organs the right
tissues and the right cells and do so in
a way that that actually reprograms
you know an adult human so you're not
having to rip the person open every time
you want to do something yeah
so that's really what motivated me to
focus all of my attention on the field
of drug and gene delivery
I took some really interesting courses
on that when I was at RPI and it did
strike me that there pretty much were
very very few actual therapeutic
implementations of that on the market
much less even in research labs that
they were actually being translated into
meaningful inventions so that's that's
kind of where I get all came from I
spent about two years at RPI as an
undergrad just working on essentially
delivering this precursor CRISPR called
the Talon another gene editing tool that
we had these really good talents
or correcting the disease of these bone
fragility mice but we didn't have any
way of actually delivering those tools
into the mice so we ended up actually
working out quite well was these
nanoparticles could be injected into the
bone marrow of the adult mouse and we
deleted a gene with 50% efficiency
across that that whole bone and we saw a
thicker bone in the injected leg
concomitant to that gene deletion so
that really sparked my interest in
spinning out a company because at the
time we were seeing you know the
beginnings of the Christopher
publications 2012-2013 but no companies
that were actually solving how we
actually gonna get Christopher to
specific cell types yep so that's that's
kind of a back story mm-hmm it's not so
many important things there okay so
something that creeps the mind right
away is you mentioned kind of what was
happening in the industry especially in
terms of the amount of data that was
this is a big thing for data we have so
much data especially on our body but we
don't know how to analyze it and make it
useful to our lives yet and we're trying
to figure that out right now and so you
saw that in the making and then you saw
that you wanted to also figure out how
to take in whatever the the drug was and
rather than you know ripping up the
human every single time it's can we make
it so that this drug can deliver what
would the molecules to the specific cell
or organ or tissue and so that is why
Gandil this yes is what you're doing
that's that is our mission our mission
is to essentially know what the precise
addresses are of the different cells
tissues and organs and actually build
the delivery systems the one-click
shopping center packages to the right
place yeah yeah how can how okay how
does one know how to get the molecule to
the heart or to the tissue or to the
cell yeah a lot of that has to do with
understanding the surface expression
profile the protein expression profile
of a given cell so
one cell will have a different set of
receptors and combinations of receptors
on its surface versus another cell
reiben yeah so the sub in each cell
proteins operate differently based on if
that cell is tremendously differently
yeah okay because then the DNA is the
same but the genes express themselves
yes different yes precisely I'll give
you an example like if we're dealing
with you know a t-cell like a specific
immune cell you know T cells express a
bunch of different markers that other
cells don't express right so you're able
to know that a t-cell is different from
this other cell so you know you can have
that molecule go towards the cells that
express a certain yes stickiness
stickiness yeah stickiness and then how
does the molecule sniff out the
stickiness um so that's where that's
this is really what a ligand is a ligand
is a molecule that binds to another
biomolecule or a molecule right so I'll
give you an example that serotonin is a
ligand for serotonin receptors mm-hmm
yeah so you have you know thousands of
different receptors in your body and
different cells are presenting different
combinations of them what we do is we we
go through you know millions of solution
spaces of how do we make these ligands
based on which proteins normally would
interact with which proteins and we
basically we dive in and we we borrow
that from biology we borrowed the native
protein sequences and then we latch
those on to the genes and the gene
therapy modalities so you can couple the
instruction to you know the address or
the zip code as opposed to hoping that
both of those things will happen at once
through you know like a small molecule
when you take a drug for example in the
ad you're in the address and
you said this is the the address versus
the instructions delivery address
instructions in the address what is what
is each again in Dunn's for us the the
address is the cell surface protein
yes yes the means for getting to that
precise address is the the polypeptide
base ligands which are derived from
natural proteins and the the
instructions are the gene editing
modality and or the gene expression
modality so CRISPR telling mRNA plasma
DNA si RNA etc okay and we can we
essentially can do these massive
combinatorial robotic screens where we
just iterate through and find the most
optimal formulation for sticking to a
specific cell coupled to whatever gene
therapy modality we want and then we
just find what works best
okay so then yeah like so you guys are
on the side of the instructions
is that right I would say instructions
coupled to delivery I believe that one
without the other cannot cannot
officially I didn't make the delivery
method we do we do we develop all the
delivery methods as well as instruction
yes but the so the delivery methods
we're not using the conventional CRISPR
one CRISPR is the thing that will be
inside the package so you know you you
order your your box from Amazon yeah
CRISPR is a thing inside the box that
needs to be you know delivered to the
right address and then carried to your
front doorstep and only then can CRISPR
actually do something when it's in the
nucleus of the cell that you want to
target only then will it actually bind
to the right sequence and cut it so you
know without that CRISPR just like any
other form of gene therapy if you inject
it into the blood it just gets destroyed
and or doesn't enter any cells so we
developed the delivery systems there are
actually nanoparticles but they're
peptide based nanoparticles
okay the delivery system is a
nanoparticle okay so you're operating on
the scale of like thousands or tens of
thousands or even nano 100 navigators a
hundred nanometer scale so that's after
like millionth is much really small and
context is you know there are billions
right yeah I million an EXO meters yeah
oh my god hundred yeah ten negative
seven yeah how do you how do you operate
on that scale um it's it's all very
visual for me kind of tumbly you you you
imagine basic interactions there
actually aren't that many interactions
you can really exploit to form something
at the nano scale you know you can
couple things together covalently
forming permanent bonds between them you
can form kind of emulsions like water
and oil having different phases and
putting you know your drugs in like the
oil phase but then the water is on the
outside and then the third principle is
using essentially charges to interact
with each other so we do a lot of
charged base stuff and figuring out how
to get the the sticky charged stuff to
be on the inside of the particle and the
ligands to be on the outside of the
particle and then coupling that to
actually what happens when you get to
the right cell how do you get that cell
to eat the particle and how do you get
in the multiple sub cellular barriers
because there are many yeah how do you
actually get the payload to the nucleus
to perform your precise instructions
that you want what is the answer that oh
well a lot of iteration and we've
developed this sort of multi layered
architecture that's almost like a multi
stage rocket if you will in that you
know if you're launching a rocket to
space you have multiple stages here you
have multiple stages in the sense that
the first stage gets you to the cell
then you enter the cell the cell has
something called endocytosis where
basically will form this little vesicle
around the the receptor bound to
whatever is on the surface and it will
literally pinch it off and pull it in
kind of like soap bubble forming from a
larger soap bubble
that's just able to close up again right
a lot of very similar actually
interactions to
that I like the multistage rocket that's
good and then you shadow you shut a
stage yeah next stage it helps you
inside the cell to target the nucleus
and then the final stage actually
releases the contents in a nuclear
specific manner using enzymes that are
specific to the nucleus and we also try
to program things like time to release
characteristics and having control over
that where you know do we want this
payload to be released over a day one
month weeks and that these are all the
things we're trying to learn a lot about
by by these massively you know high
throughput is essentially iterative
approaches to developing the most
optimal formulation for different
purpose okay so then you guys write the
instructions and make the delivery
missus okay and then you've also
analyzed the cells that you're trying to
just receive that are trying to receive
it they optimize the approach of how to
get there it's processing it okay so now
let's do an example of sickle cell
anemia okay that seems to be like the
one that is been worked on like them
okay let's that's a great example so
right now there are a few labs that are
and let me see you see if I'm right is
it a dead blood cells have trouble
carrying oxygen yeah yeah yeah a great
example I'm really happy you brought
that one up actually so couple wines
people a hundred thousand yeah in the US
yes yeah well sickle cells an
interesting disease because you have
it's a rare disease you have a hundred
thousand people need us to have it as
many as like forty percent of people in
North Africa and some Middle Eastern
populations between sickle cell and the
thalassemias which are similar but not
all listicle actually have that much and
in countries like Africa sorry in
continents like Africa you have this
issue where essentially malaria if you
have sickle cell disease you don't get
malaria or you don't die from malaria
nearly as often hmm
if you have it yeah you don't does
protective so just as a kind of a
bookmark you know yeah we should be
careful with that one yeah
because in a hamburger I want to yeah
that's so good here in the US we can we
can start piloting some stuff okay a
couple labs are making some really great
headway one of them is Matthew 40s is
live out of Stanford they're actually
doing some of the first ex-vivo where
essentially you have to take the Hamada
poetic stem cells that will eventually
turn into red blood cells out of your
body and then genetically reprogram them
so no longer have the sickle cell
disease mutation and then you
reimplantation
but then how do they tell the other
cells to carry oxygen well again so the
amount of products M cells are normally
these really rare cells they they
persist through the light for life they
can be anywhere between one and 40,000
of your cells like in your blood in your
bone marrow all the way to maybe like
10% that will have some basic markers
for being able to divide a lot that
they're basically stem cells
subpopulations right and so they can
divide so many times we're talking like
thousands of times like a lot right so
you don't need that many
you just need there's actually a
protocol where you will condition the
body to no longer carry its own stem
cells after you take some of them out
you kill off some of the other ones so
that the new ones can in craft and grow
and proliferate so what we're doing is a
little bit different we're not taking
the cells out of the body they're
putting the nanoparticles into the body
to try to stem cells and reprogram so in
the case of sickle cell disease
you only need to correct a single amino
acid in that hemoglobin B gene mm-hmm
other things are more complex but
actually they're about one amino acid
yeah that's it yeah there's there's just
one amino acid that's messed up in the
whole protein there's a couple of these
diseases that are just an amino acid
about 6,000 of them male diseases that
are just one amino acid a single genes
at least they might be a few you know a
few amino acids but they're single genes
that could be corrected Wow about 8% of
the u.s. population has as one or more
genetic mutations essentially that
correlate to rare disease mm-hm
and the majority then don't have any
therapies actually and then a lot of
stuff a lot of other stuff is more
complex right so if we start talking
about oncology and essentially you know
people getting cancer that's less likely
to be just a single gene that you were
born with and a lot of environmental
factors and damage over time and who
knows what else right so that's another
approach where it actually amino
oncology is really really promising and
that's also something that we're
focusing on a lot and which is
essentially can we reprogram immune
cells to kill cancer cells based on
genetically were programming them to
have the correct instructions and this
is actually the first gene therapy that
got approved last year in the u.s. Wow
chimera by Novartis yeah it's an
autologous T cell transplantation where
they they currently will have to take
these T cells out of your body and they
basically use lentiviruses which are
like HIV that doesn't divide anymore and
carries the gene insertion that you want
as opposed to inserting more HIV right
so you insert these things called
chimeric antigen receptors onto the T
cells which we're basically like an
antibody fragment on the outside of the
T cell that will stick to a specific
marker so in the case of like b-cell
leukemia you can actually target the
b-cell leukemia and kill it problem is
that it will also kill your healthy
b-cells but these are like terminal
patients who don't really have much
option in the standard of care
that's kind of the feel you know that
you can do so much if you can if you can
actually just deliver you uncover
essentially the full creative force of
humanity for whatever we want to do is
this also able to assist with restoring
homeostatic capacity like youthful
homeless I class I really hope so so
that's that's something that I'm really
interested in for a number of reasons
and I think that in showing that we can
deliver on a cell tissue an organ
specific level these regenerative
medicine approaches become extremely
practical because you know take things
like you know you had Aubree on here for
example if you want to target senescence
cells and kill senescence cells off you
could start to do that if you know that
there's something unique about the
surface profile of the essence exactly
you can deliver killing instructions and
you can similarly you're on the way to
hopefully learn that yeah yeah exactly
and we can use all the data that people
generate around the world and by
focusing on really the goal is can we
have a two day turnaround time for what
genetic instructions do you want to
deliver and where at that point it
becomes you know we're just playing with
biology like we're having computers yeah
yeah I'm really excited for that I'm
really excited for that I know we're
yeah the healthcare industry is so ready
for this and then there's all the
complications around pharma and
hospitals there's all the complications
around that as well that they're also
behind on and it's funny because AI and
nanotech and all these methods of of
exponentially increasing technology are
now influencing an industry that is kind
of a little oh gee in some ways and so
now how the healthcare industry is about
to be torn into by these technologies
and it's going to expand I just I wonder
how it's going to work in a way that
hopefully is able to impact more people
but if not if there's so much money
that's currently being concentrated in
the orphan disease area of research
if we can figure out how to take that
money and distribute better gene
therapies across populations of people
there could be a significant savings and
the amount of money that we spend on any
time I think that's a huge I mean look I
think the goal if you just model this if
the cost of producing a gene therapy is
essentially a a trend that is just
decreasing even somewhat exponentially
let's say mm-hmm know which it is yeah
it's it's very inexpensive quickly it's
gonna get really inexpensive quickly I
love that so what if it costs with say a
thousand dollars to deliver any set of
genetic instructions anywhere in your
body either temporarily permanently
amazing thousand bucks yeah amazing your
margins start changing a lot yeah
because suddenly you can actually you
don't need to hike up the price of your
drug to five hundred thousand or 1.5
million per patient because you have
only a few thousand patients you know
you can actually afford to really take
on a super personalized medicine thesis
and people are actually getting access
to this level of care there's less
reactive care like we currently have
where you spend you know weeks in a
hospital bed spending you know two
thousand dollars a day on your hospital
bed now it's you know you get an
injection you go home and hopefully
you're better and I think there's a
tremendous cost saving aspect to that
and oncology is you know a huge burden
on on also just society I mean solid
tumors and human to logical malignancies
also known as just liquid tumors
basically cancer as a whole is projected
to be I believe 169 billion dollar
market by 2025 just in the u.s. so
that's absurd
I'm so as so as we take all the money
that we say from orphan diseases and
then if we make it a thousand dollars to
send any genetic therapy to any part of
the body permanently or temporarily that
that's gonna assure in a new era of of
the way that we not only treat genetic
disease but also that we try and augment
human experience yes are you guys ready
for that you know I think there's gonna
be a lot of stuff that needs to be
figured out and they're clear you know
ethical implications and a lot of things
that need to be deeply thought about and
you know we're trying to take it one
step at a time in terms of defining okay
you know these are the first sets of
diseases that we're going to target
we're going to show that on a cell type
basis you know like if I can target a
t-cell or hematopoietic stem cell I can
uncover all these therapeutic modalities
and from there as the business grows you
know that that's always something that I
think it needs to be continuous dialogue
I mean as we're seeing with even just
Facebook and and this congressional
testimony that you know you can't
predict all these things a lot of it it
happens life and you need to just be
ready to to take it as it comes and
adapt and do it you know what ultimately
is is the best thing you can
the bioethics is very fascinating mm-hmm
I don't think we're ready for bioethics
yeah human sibelius humans are not ready
for bioethics what we are ready for is
through reading dinner at genetic just
disease I think we aren't start with
that we can start with that okay so we
have you know these single gene
mutations that's that's a that's an
easier one to target cancer cells can
sometimes be maybe multiple multi gene
mutation maybe even a emit a certain
characteristic that we can sniff out and
go and very much I really like nano text
great for some cancer sonal and in some
cases not all of solid tumors you have
something called leaky vasculature where
essentially the tumor grows fast enough
so that the blood vessels are a little
bit leaky so if you have nanoparticles
that are nanoparticles they actually
will seep through and accumulate in the
tumor ooh yes and and I think with these
sort of approaches if you're actually
able to target different cells you can
start to play with multi multi cellular
multi organ system dynamics also and
because you're basically able to say I
can you know delete or insert any trait
that I want in any cell so I think the
the more multimodal therapies become the
most interesting and I'll give you
another example even in like the
neurodegenerative disease you know
Parkinson's disease ALS all these other
diseases the minority of cases are just
a single gene actually so like
Parkinson's is well known to have this
one gene called lark too and if it's
mutated you have a high probability of
getting Parkinson's disease
so that's that's less than 10% I think
it's like 5 to 10% of people with
Parkinson's disease so then there are
approaches that are quite promising for
being able to address these multi genic
implications of this so you know my good
friend Katerina Voss is working on a
company called Occam's razor and what
they're doing is they're taking these
massive data sets of Parkinson's disease
from all these people and essentially
figuring out hey like what is actually
unique to this person that's driving
their Parkinson's disease mm-hmm
with gene therapy modalities that are
non viral and truly customizable you can
start to approach these diseases on a
one-off basis and just say hey now these
seven genes are messed up let's let's go
in there and fix them and no one's doing
that right now it is the closest thing
that people are doing I think the
immunotherapy and the immuno engineering
is the most complex set of genetic
engineering circuits that I've seen so
far I think that stuff's really
interesting these adapters in how do you
actually program an immune cell to have
affinity for a given yeah marker but
also how do you program the signaling
and the activation of that t-cell so
that actually divides and activates and
you know mounts a killing response so
people are programming the full
circuitry yeah yeah
ah that's stuff I love the way you speak
about it it's just it's it's just so
enthusiastic and it's also I think
you're doing a good job of making it
relatable but it's it's really difficult
stuff without and without any biological
understanding it's very difficult with
minimal biological understanding I think
you're tapping in a little bit but then
of course everyone that's watching that
is totally biologically savvy they're
all over it there they know everything
that your should we give a primer on
like the central dogma of molecular
biology yeah
please so DNA turns to RNA turns to
protein is that's kind of the central
dogma it's the idea that you have this
genetic code in your nucleus and you
have about 3 billion letters and those
letters get read out into RNA which is
the way that you amplify that signal
because you know you have like one gene
you need to create a lot of copies of it
and then those mRNA strands they go
through and the essentially the end of
plasmic reticulum and they become
proteins ribosomes and the prospect
particularly the ribosome section what
does an RNA expressed from DNA DNA
though helix RNA to chunk the letters
RNA how does how does RNA even come from
that chunk of letters and then how does
it get expressed you have like
polymerize polymerase is yeah run along
you essentially have like your genome
and then it will be read out into RNA by
RNA polymerase and a number of other
there are a lot of different like
transcriptional and sia
basically one of them is responsible for
literally like spewing together the
sequence that matches the DNA sequence
yeah
and that will then be exported from the
nucleus and then go through and the
ribosomes actually will have transfer
RNA where there's a single amino acid
corresponding to three base pairs that
will as the mRNA is going through
they'll match up and they'll daisy chain
together and that's how you get a
polypeptide that eventually comes to
protein so that's the central dogma
that's like the classical biology right
the anime RNA proved yeah and nowadays
you know we're learning there there are
all these other everything interacts
with everything so you have RNA
interacting with RNA you have proteins
interacting with RNA you have
ribonucleoproteins raipur you know
everything is everything you have
transcription factors which are proteins
that bind to specific DNA sequences and
you know cause genes to be read out more
or less and things like that it's it's
highly dynamic but also yes also in in
this beautiful way that I really love
about biology because it's all parallel
it's all happening at the same time
nonetheless it's coherent somehow we're
conscious and somehow also you can do
very predictable things with biology it
has this stability and this coherence
within it that survives against all that
chaotic complexity
the human machine is so beautiful and
it's so so complex and then everything
that you're describing about it is so
many years of research by swathes of
people that have really gotten deep into
the human body and how it works and okay
so
let's see if I can go all the way back
all right Ryan though like you I can't
like handle for ligand oh how is let's
hear let's see if I can do this we have
the information and we have it being
sent this so the information is being
sent to the address in the body and the
information is put in there through
nanomedicine so you've at this 100
nanometer scale of putting together the
molecules that need to be put together
in order to sniff out that's those
specific cells okay and then the the
deliverance method is injection or
world I will be oral yet but it will be
eventually injection yeah I get an
injection of this nano medicine and then
it enters in through my bloodstream and
then it sniffs out the cell that it
needs to get to and then there's the
multistage rocket that gets it into the
nucleus of this okay yes and then that's
where the DNA is and that's what it's
able to make the changes through either
CRISPR or through the Cassadine protein
or through the other ones that you
listed is that thing
and so we describe ourselves it's like
payload agnostic right because we are
getting a package there nothing okay I'm
happy I'm happy that I can at least have
a point zero one percent understanding
of what's going on it's precisely
correct I hope I hope I hope I can get
better at this as a science communicator
it can be really difficult you're a very
gentle and kind person I'm telling you
thank you because most most people that
you operate a great does not give you
time to be gentle or kind he's like
freaking running around being like if
you don't understand biology I
time we need to go and get people out of
Pro aging trance and you're like it's
okay like yeah I'll take let's take our
time let's get through this and I think
I think I think we got through at least
enough to get that bare foundational
level understanding okay let's go back
to this information again so the
information that's going to the address
the information besides being the right
molecules that will sniff out the right
cell what else is being added to that as
a nano medicine and the multistage is
you have already said the multi stages
but like how do you know how to equip a
or what is it a hemoglobin stem cell no
I'm not afford X times at home you call
it an HHS see if you want HS see a whole
meadow poetic stem so how do you how
does it how does how do you program the
nano medicine to to tell that homo
products stem cell to proliferate more
and to take off or help with sickle cell
anemia yeah that's a great question and
that's something that you know we're
really pioneering also because you you
touched on an interesting point which is
not just the reprogramming of the cell
but also the proliferation so we are
doing combination delivery also and we
were I think the first company to
deliver like a gene editing you know lab
nuclear protein like Christopher along
with an mRNA LSA and we did these
studies actually in monkey bone marrow
in seinem august monkey bone marrow
taking just the bone marrow and looking
at the different subpopulations of like
stem cells versus immune cells and so on
that are eating up the CRISPR payloads
and you know we're able to get it in
like we can get merciful payloads
multiple instructions in so what does
this mean for the perspective of how do
you actually reprogram the hematopoietic
stem cell to no longer have sickle cell
disease well there are two ways that you
can do that one is there's actually a
gene that you can delete it's kind of a
hack if you if you just cut in this one
spot it actually causes your cells to
start producing fetal hemoglobin
which you don't produce after your fetus
but the fetal hemoglobin is able to
rescue a lot of the oxygen carrying
capacity the slightly harder thing to do
is to actually replace the gene of
interest with the new sequence it's easy
to cut it's harder to paste and there's
actually a delta and an error rate
between those two processes however you
can actually cut around the area of
where that it's it's called an e 7v
mutation it's the seventh amino acid
basically a includes glutamic acid that
is swapped for a valine and you need to
swap it back so you can actually cut or
perform some sort of obstruction of just
the DNA either a single-stranded break
or a double-stranded break and then you
provide a template for repair a couple
of other approaches no longer require
the cut and paste approach so like David
Lou's group at Harvard came up with a
way to do essentially just replacing a
single base they call him base editing
and similarly you would use actually
like a a modified cast protein with the
guide RNA that actually homes into the
right section of the genome and then you
will actually metabolize one of the base
pairs into a different base pair so
that's like more per site that would be
more precise when it measures well how
many people are right now working on
eleven eleven people and it's mostly
scientists mostly in the field of
nanomedicine
very multidisciplinary oh yeah super
multidisciplinary so like we have shell
laying he was the first person to work
with CRISPR he was actually at MIT and
the Broad Institute back in 2011 and he
yeah just like very good at geo
missionary moss then we have like Ryan
he's a peptide chemist he was like a
Laura Lawrence Berkeley National Labs he
built us like a beautiful peptide robot
that's like 60 times faster than
anything money can buy and you just type
in the amino acid sequence you want and
it will spit it out so you can see how
how you like those two things combined
already kind of explains a lot of stuff
and we have people like who used to work
at Genentech and stuff like that working
on
coal's nano formulations Wow chemical
engineering biophysics you know
biochemistry and material science and
engineering
you know molecular biology cell biology
sheena visionary peptide is very loose
and also the AI the robotics the machine
learning the actual building of the
processes for once you actually know the
physical parameters of how to form nano
medicine which is complex but once you
actually figure out yeah once you
actually figure out how to make good
particles and you can start changing
which segments in code for what whether
it be the gene or the protein that is
actually targeting another protein we
can do a lot mm-hmm
automation as well become it's also
automated us it's kind of the whole yeah
that's so good okay so you guys have you
guys just it's series a or how long ago
traducere is it around last year okay
well we'll have an announcement on it
later this year June okay it would be
some great news thank you thank you good
awesome who are some of the investors
from the previous own you know social
capital Chris Larson from ripple and
Esther Dyson
oh great Wallach Parker Institute of
cancer immunotherapy I mean we have
probably 50 best investors at this dish
nice thank you oh yeah thank you guys
yeah yeah I think yeah yeah like super
thanks to them things would not be air
and if well and also super thanks to the
vision and the execution and the whole
team yeah that builds a new team is
incredible like without a team I mean he
used to be just you know two three
people or you know Christian or CTO just
like literally being let me get
everything to work by myself and like
I'm like let's get us some money you
know yeah it used to be the the role you
know now we can actually just like work
on all these pieces it's just really
exciting
many clients are currently using the
technology we're not on a client based
system at all yeah we're really
developing the technology internally and
doing all of the everything up to the
clinical scale and stage of
manufacturing ourselves so we're we're
in the process of building out a
facility that will actually allow us to
do clinical grade and clinical skill
manufacturing of all of this stuff and
it's gonna happen it's gonna have a
robotic iron mentum I'll talk about that
to us like that is very exciting so so
the you're building out a whole facility
so you're doing the vertical oh you're
doing the vertical and the horizontal
and in the horizontal the the the the
interesting thing is then I will come
into your clinic and after you get FDA
approval for this and then I will leave
your clinic having this $1,000 yeah yeah
and and like to set expectations I mean
like a thousand dollar mark is one where
we really like personalized and also
yeah we want to build clinics like that
is the long-term goal but you know I
mean yeah like long term I I won't
really want to see this where you can
step into a clinic and get medicine
right that right but in the interim in
this rare disease and amino oncology
space yeah it's actually a very hot
space for partnering and something that
we're very interested in yeah because
also as a as a R&D focused organization
we all want to take on all of the
clinical development ourselves we don't
want to have to take on all the
marketing and distribution and so on
that's necessary to actually conduct a
clinical trial and go to market so we're
focused on getting good data and then
finding good partners to do that but
because we have this foundational
infrastructure and full supply chain and
just knowledge of how to build the right
technology for X application that's
where we can you know we basically
become in we enter the business of
essentially venture creation and
partnering and driving down costs and
making things really widely available
yes yes and then once it's once you're
approaching in that point where I can
actually feasibly inject you with
whatever instructions I want for a
thousand dollars that's rare
we yeah that's where the whole model
just becomes different I think and you
might still actually lean I think Pharma
will have a strong role so I think yeah
and I think farmer will continue having
roll in just kind of this this
infrastructure as is evidenced by a lot
of just the M&A activity in the gene
therapy landscape across Pharma like a
vexes a gene therapy company that was
just using viruses to reprogram spinal
muscular atrophy in neonates our
children like very very young infants um
they basically they showed that they
could correct this disease in 16
patients and they just got bought for
think eight point seven billion dollars
in cash from Novartis and that's like
Phase two data right so I think oh my
gosh
yeah and that's like one one application
with promise maybe we can do some more
some more things right so if you
actually personalize it and what if it
doesn't cost 150,000 per person yeah
your first ones will yeah yeah you know
yeah yeah staging staging is everything
it's like time the market with the the
goal of you know doing social good and
actually making things accessible yep
yep let's pull up your the email that
you that you sign with the deck really
let me get connected to this and then
it's coming up
as I think this deck looked the one deck
it's a good deck to get back but we have
a skin converters on but I'm also a
little slow on okay there we go
Andre updated okay there we go
Thanks all right we go up until 4 ru you
see it it on oh all right
let me quit scan converter quick
all right I just turned it back on
but all right so here's an investor
brief for you
all right assumption of engineering you
can have the fanciest ideas and
molecules but if you can't get them into
the cell they are of no use yep
and that's the getting it from
instructions to the address now I said
super that's so relatable I'm really
like that
yeah bring the understanding of genetics
and immunotherapy Billy's I was invested
into CRISPR no gene therapies we like
the delivery mechanisms necessary sherry
will reprogram diseases in bill humans
to biological equivalent of the last
mile
dragons
the weather team tape is exactly where
they need to go biomolecules that stick
to the other biomolecules binding to a
precise receptor profiles for targeted
cell populations
in vivo gene engineering
super personalized medicine single IV
injections
biggest element of medical history boom
I like it I like it that's the dream
I think we're 10 years away from this
sort of an interface where you're just
like you're strapped in and I'm looking
at your actual visualized your actual
DNA and I'm like oh you want this I want
that okay great well you can already go
to like cyntha go calm and define a
target genetic locus and get a CRISPR
design the whole target that sequence
and now 20 seconds so we're pretty close
doing pretty well wait what yeah that's
like 50 bucks whoa
yeah so you can get the information yeah
you need to but then the mechanism of
deliveries yeah you can get it actually
delivered to you not delivered you can
get cyndago will literally shipped to
you the the guide RNA that targets the
right genetic locus right whoa and you
couple that to the caste line protein
getting in to get at it getting its into
the specific cells of interest is where
we kick in yeah yeah and those two are
gonna be I think very much like that
damn
okay what else shall we
about liking though what else is really
important to talk about stimulation
course now we're gonna talk simulation
like yeah yeah whoo I'm excited for
simulation questions I think I think
we've covered a lot I mean I think this
idea of creating super personalized even
multimodal therapies that can cover the
whole gamut of health and human disease
it's really a matter of we need the zip
codes may need the addresses we need the
delivery mechanisms and from there all
of the stuff that anyone is doing around
the world trying to you know gene edit
or you know engineer a circuit of
genetic activity or some sort of you
know therapy like all of that just
becomes kind of one just like we don't
view you know our computer keyboard is
different from our monitor or from the
computer itself it's all you know you
can type you can delete you can insert
it's all it's all seamless it's not it's
not disjointed but forty years ago it
was you didn't have a UX mm-hmm so it's
creating that and implementing it and
making it so that it's not you know a
bunch of scientists spending 16 hours a
day with pipettes but rather people
actually thinking and kind of pushing
the direction of the evolution of the
technology
and then there's like that pipetting
robot from open Tron's as well I thought
that was really interesting for the
industry we have one you have one have
an open B of two there are two open
traps will ya will shout out
okay let's since I mean since this is
our topic of the day I'm excited let's
talk about this then how will first how
will we work together across the world
as for example China's AI budget is now
great the largest in the world the
genetic engineering a way or we were
hesitant but they're running with it
they're tying it out they want to play
what do you think about that how do we
work together as the world to hopefully
not create bio warfare or any other
issues that could arise from injecting
somebody that go just goes and kills
their heart or whatever it is that
already exists but um well the the
pessimistic optimist in me I'm not gonna
say my I'm not gonna say any
bioterrorism ideas today because I would
say you know if you really if you really
want to kill someone polio or smallpox
works right like we don't know we don't
need I think I don't know I think there
are all sorts of crazy ways that you
could use nanotechnology for for evil
Wow
but I also think that viruses or
nanotechnology and that's quite you know
quite potent yeah and I think that you
know the sort of technology we're
developing will also be able to mount
very good defenses against those sort of
things and I think that there is a huge
offense component to this because you
know immunological reprogramming to
specific characteristics as something
that we will be able to do and you can
create massive firewalls inside your
body yeah I mean you can create a
firewall around your
all of your human cells so that way
bioterrorism can't happen well I think
you I think it's always a hacking and
counter counter counter hacking like I
just like we have right now right you're
not you're not gonna get you know iOS
9.2 and then hey this is it you know
it's got to keep updating so I think
that now we have different selection
pressures as humans as just evolving
organisms where we have this
technological component now that's
entering and actually pushing our
evolution right and that's something
that can be used for good or for evil
which are very relative terms but I know
yeah being evil is underrated
you know what is this with $150,000 to
start for for delivering information to
the right address and then over time
hopefully getting that down to a
thousand dollars for these gene
therapies yeah do you think that this
could exacerbate wealth inequality
always and yeah that's that's a big
component I think figuring out how to
provide healthcare for people who don't
have the money to pay for it is
something that I'm really excited about
frankly because if if I can bring my
cost of goods down to a hundred dollars
yes then you know I mean I think you
know a billionaire should pay a lot of
money to get a gene therapy because
they're a billionaire but like that
should also be subsidizing like a
hundred people who don't have right yeah
and I think that that as companies we
have to take stances on these sort of
just dilemmas and issues pretty early on
saying yeah okay like we need to drill
towards this right and the conscious
capitalism yeah yeah we just had a
meeting with the CEO of conscious
capitalism Alexander he's gonna come on
the show that's that's huge the fact
that it's built into your values at such
a young stage
is super indicative of now going out and
naturally doing that and making sure
that that actually happens then getting
somebody on board like you're paying
$10,000 so that you can subsidize you
know the hundred other people no yeah
so that's boom that's so cool okay how
about
what is something that you believe to be
true that almost nobody else believes to
be true found that the bio biology is a
something that can be highly
programmable and that but I don't gather
people think that but that I believe it
in like okay there's by there's Dave
Asprey biohacking and then there's like
cell specific genetic engineering like
you know grass-fed butter versus sorry
you know yeah all I'm saying here is
there's there's biohacking and then
there's precision engineering of you
know deep biological traits on a
deterministic level where it's like you
now possess this trade or you no longer
have the strain and I think that's not
something that people really grok yet on
on a high level I think a lot of people
were into bio hacking or they they liked
the idea of gene therapy like can I get
you know different color dyes or get
different colored hair or you know
something else
yeah like that's that's where I think we
need to teach people this language of
different cells having different
addresses and essentially start thinking
about things that way because that's
where the next breakthrough happens
that's where like biohacking becomes
wait we're actually buying a hacking
yeah okay okay no I'm more following
yeah I still think some people more
people most people think that way maybe
than you think I hope so I say I hope so
it's not here yes no here yes yeah I
think globally maybe not yeah yeah how
about do you think we're alone in the
cosmos oh boy I doubt it
doubt it where does the older grass
Tyson thing
my mom was certain he thinks that
there's a one out of every five stars
house isn't he back on the god thing
didn't he didn't I just did I read that
he's he endorsed the god theory
I don't think okay a guy yeah yeah but I
know that he's had a bunch of people on
his shows recently that are religious
and I think he's trying to bring the
conversation up at least Moore's more
because God doesn't necessarily just
mean religious God God means who the
Kosmos in general the universe in
general is you know that's one
understanding then there's something
among us that wants us to believe it's
God which is also trying to figure out
what God is as well now that's something
to think about and ponder it goes to the
it's all about the God and the devil
thing and then you have to be real
careful everybody wants to talk you know
so the cows come home about God but you
start talking about the devil and
everybody shuts up uh-huh that's very
sorry go back to yeah was the question
are we alone yet yeah I got it and okay
so then how about are we in a computer
simulation what do you think I think I
think the computer is overrated I think
it's a Silicon Valley hype cycle event
but what what is a simulation right and
what is a computer so
so then is the question so then what is
your answer well I think at okay my
answer is multi-dimensional um you know
if you could model the whole universe
and truly understand both directionality
and position of every single bit of
resolution within that universe then in
in theory at that level you'd be saying
okay well this is like a simulation
because I actually have modeled all this
and I know exactly how it's going to
behave and everything is just like
physical constants and somehow accounted
for but I also don't think that's how
the universe works and then a universe
is like a highly parallel kind of tumbly
massive of you know parallel splitting
off realities into many things or even
if it's you know one reality like it's
it's still so convoluted in so complex
that that to me that's that's almost the
less interesting question then can we
program universal constants that's cool
and that's where the answer is yes
mm-hmm
yeah yeah but then if we actually live
in one if we can tap into understanding
that better will awaken us mm-hmm but
yeah I I think so too
can we program every single plank every
single vibration mm-hmm and how much of
that is dictated by our consciousness
yeah uh I mean just say coming up with
the concept of creating something or
creating something that's that requires
you to look around you and see that
something doesn't exist
your minds like I want nothing to exist
and then you you will actually change
your behavior and usually the behavior
of other people also to create something
where something didn't exist that's
that's pretty crazy if you think about
it
yeah and then over do you think that
what what is consciousness
oh boy let's consciousness
I mean consciousness is a state of being
and being aware that you are being maybe
okay okay
presence but do you do you think really
thinks the most beautiful thing in the
world most beautiful thing in the world
and being able to be in the moment and
be peaceful and just yeah like actually
just being Reyes like those those
moments really great doesn't matter
where it is it's like in your mind
that's mm-hmm it's the best
ah alright that was solid that was
amazing
yeah I really enjoyed that I'm really
I'm really happy that you came up I have
so much just to learn about biotech and
about gene therapy and about
personalized medicine and about how you
do nano medicine how you deliver it and
then how you get it in this multi stage
to the nucleus and get it worked you'll
be releasing some just like white papers
and educational materials on you know I
think that's really a goal of one of my
goals too and the goal of our company is
to end you can just help people to
understand what's going on because it's
like complex set of converging fields
that yes yeah
and hopefully recruit more and hopefully
build out your your first uses of this
in in humans as soon as possible yeah
and I really I really hope that in the
next you know two or three years we can
start to see some interventions making
what yes the clinic zones it's really oh
yes pushing for that yeah all right
everyone at home if you had a good time
give us a like give us a comment you
subscribe if you found this content
useful share it with other people you
know we got the like indels leaked links
in the bio we would love for you to
check them out they have all they have a
really beautiful video on their homepage
to also kind of you know get you
understanding it better as well if you
guys also think that this this type of
content is great become a patron we
would totally need your help we need to
you know we have rent we have production
costs we have our food electricity all
these people all these things help us
out help us grow let's get those impact
more people around the world and thank
you so much Andre we really appreciate
you thank you and thank you Ronnie
shakin - okay Ron our producer and
director thank you so much Ron and we'll
catch you guys tomorrow
[Music]
you